horizon zero dawn not too far away like
four weeks almost exactly yeah just went
gold yes you was ready to release from
our guerrilla games froth Killzone fame
but really big shift for them obviously
its third person open worlds in action
with RPG elements very different yeah
and Kelly you went you really went down
to a preview event at in Los Angeles yes
and you got to play more so we played at
e3 Scott Butterworth i believe and Jake
Decker both played a few preview events
and they got like smaller chunks of the
open world to explore yeah for my
understanding it wasn't it was more
combat focus like Oh dropping you into a
combat situation where I got to play
what I presume was the beginning of the
game I think for the first hour and a
half and then for another two and a half
hours I played just kind of explored and
crafted and looked at the skill tree a
whole bunch and ended a lot of combat
and climbed a giant machine so you have
a preview up on gamespot which if after
the show you guys can all go read for
more in-depth preview as the game is
approaching release Kelly wrote it it's
very good i read through it and i'm
really excited for the game now I try
I've actually this is one of those games
I've been you know it's one of the
things if I didn't work at gamespot I
would try to watch preview footage much
less just so I'm actually I don't know a
ton about the games when they come out
but yeah by the nature of our job we
kind of have to this is one the games I
was trying to avoid but obviously for
the segment today and whatnot I read up
more on it after you had written your
preview and I'm excited for it i'm i
think my questions mainly revolve around
the gameplay loop how it works in
general the structure of it because
we've seen they released a cinematic
trailer recently yeah we're watching
right now kind of shows more the games
very story oriented um we can go into
the premise of it soon but I guess we
could just kind of do a general
roundabout of how the game works because
I think there's a lot a lot of people
are talking about you said like III they
showed off a combat and whatnot yes
understanding i didn't get to play it at
three but um yeah I've been excited
about this game ever since i saw it i
feel like i have the exact same hair she
does so i got really good um i started
an end the protagonist name from
Heavenly Sword I'll look it up whatever
good yeah but um uh yeah basically I was
trying to figure out what like a typical
gameplay loop would look like
and it's a lot of hunting down the
machines for parts so one of the early
missions is like literally to just get
some parts so you can get fire arrows to
go on it like a to attack a bigger
machine um and so there's a lot of that
I found it really satisfying because um
the weaponry is obviously very like
ancient and inspired there's bow and
arrow Spears and stuff like that but
being able to effectively kill a machine
doesn't seem as weird and contradictory
as it initially is like it sounds like
okay well how's an arrow going to do any
damage to like a metal to the
saber-toothed tiger thank you ty fire
arrow yeah yeah it just doesn't make any
sense but there she has like a scanning
device and it looks like sort of like a
bluetooth wearable and glass you gets it
yeah you get to uh oh hi somebody since
I inject you get to play as her as a
like a six-year-old for a very brief
amount of time and that's when she finds
it and you can scan the area you can
track sort of where a machine is if they
have like a set path and then one of the
things you can do is highlight their
weak points um and that makes the arrow
strike oh and I freaking trophy oh yeah
she's wrong when I was capturing um and
I so it felt more natural than I thought
it would be I guess is what I'm saying
so I found that really satisfying um the
variety of machines we got to see a
little bit more initially there's like
the Watchers which will call more to you
come so the main strategy there is to
just take out the Watchers first and
then there's kind of this big that I
don't I think it's a saw tooth or
something like that um damn like instead
of a saber-tooth they just have saws for
teeth I made sure I didn't get a good
look at its teeth because I was running
away from it okay so here's here's my
thing and this is not a negative comment
but I think a lot of people are
comparing it to far cry in third person
you know the hunting gathering
open-world stealth or action and then
three skill tree did it feel like far
card games to you yeah i would i would
say that's a fair compare mine fire car
game is to an honest even this right
here yeah i'll post you take over here
nothing you what you you send in at hurt
you take it over and your tribe will
then spawn there or live there right or
something that is far cry primal yeah
right um yeah that was just like we were
investing I think I had to investigate a
some somebody there was like a massacre
and I was investigating it um this is
where I got to climb a giant machine it
was really cool um yeah so it I think
that's a fair comparison I do think that
the one of the big drivers for me to
keep playing is figuring out why the
world is the way it is because obviously
it's far future I think it's a thousand
years in the future post
post-apocalyptic and I'm really curious
to see like what the deal with that is
like I feel like there were a lot of
hints in the demo I played toward what
that would be but I didn't get a lot of
information so i think that's the main
like if you're wondering like oh why
should I play this if I you know I hope
it's good already yeah I hope it's like
like oh damn I story I know I hope ya so
here's yeah I hope this isn't spoiling
anything I don't think it is but alright
there's a short story from back in the
day July thirty-first 1937 by Stephen
Vincent Benet um I it's Nariko nariko by
the way from my Heavenly Sword thank you
a few people said it bones Nelson said
that um anyway by the waters of babylon
if you get the chance to read it if
you're excited for horizon rita it's a
short story you could find like a PDF if
you search by the waters of babylon the
first thing comes up on google as the
PDF it is i don't want now i don't wanna
spoil the short story its its horizon
zero dawn member last time we did this
in the lobby and i said i think they got
washed out to from bedazzled oh god damn
it and then we found out holy ship it as
was set in san francisco much like watch
dogs to their again okay by the waters
babylon is a story about you've heard it
here first yes it's a story about these
people in this tribal society that go to
these places to find metal it's it's the
currency then you start to find out
there's a huge twist to it you can read
the short story now the twist isn't as
novel but i remember reading this store
shorts are in like seventh grade me like
holy [ __ ] and it sounds a lot like
horizon and I have my suspicions that
they might be going this route but check
it out by the waters of babylon by
Stephen Vincent Benet I would just want
it not to be we made the machines and
the machines took over
like I don't want the Terminator with
the accent biggest like I'm right there
with ya like that it came with an accent
yeah a lot of different oxidant it's
like the it's the beginning of the movie
a wee boy yeah where I mean like my
initial before I thought start thinking
about this short story was maybe like a
nuclear war happened and then like
tribal warfare sprouted back up sure but
would you even need nukes in a thousand
years when you have these robots but the
robot seem they're like autonomous right
there they're wild animals well no you
can override them and use one type of
them as a mount and then the Watchers
don't seem like the other ones seem to
be like I'll holden to the Watchers ok
so but I can't say for certain ok oh i
think there's something going on they're
gonna know so in terms of the ones that
look like brontosaurus with like
starship enterprises on their head that
yeah Rob you describe them as that so
are like a map they're unlocking parts
of the map yeah you climb up and it's
like radar like radio towers yeah ok and
again I'm not I'm not downplaying this
because it seems like fall out it's a
lot of other games have kind of mimics
fallout 3's or fall out tues open-world
structure it's over that cascading
structure of opening the map getting
more quests which lead to other quests
which leads to items which leads the
hunting which leads to skills worse
leads back to the rest yeah I don't mind
that but I would love if his game felt
really unique uh as of now I just could
see it feeling like a far cry game but
yeah I I mean I can play tonight I have
not I'm really excited for it i'm really
looking forward to playing more um for
the combat you you had your opinions on
the combat to how it yeah into the world
it feels like it feels good yeah you can
read all about that on gamespot com yeah
um and also there's a more gameplay that
you can check out and we have for cake
gameplay as well um is this game does
look really good yeah real always kind
of nails on the head with the visuals
yeah I think the only thing was the
camera was a little wonky for me okay um
but like at some points um but yeah so
the combat like I said it like the
weapons don't feel ineffective but you
also don't feel overpowered and I like
the skill how the skill tree feeds into
combat
in kind of shapes how I played I focused
more on stealth while I was there so I'm
excited to try different routes and
everything like that um I'm just really
looking forward to playing more I didn't
really want to leave I had to catch a
flight cuz as a day trip along do you
play we do have questions four and a
half hours okay cool um I'm gonna throw
some questions at you and you might a
lot of these you might not even know or
any of us I know but I'll allah i'll
pick ones that you might so did you get
a sense of the scope of the map because
adam Roston on twitter head said how
does Corizon how does her resin compared
to other open world as far as scope and
scale I mean it's always hard to compare
games like you know grand theft auto 5
to the witcher but I just feel big um I
can't really tell there was a lot of fog
of war kind of stuff on the map um so
the climbing up on that I think it's
called a long neck person on long necks
tall neck I was like that's that is the
land before time yeah um oh yeah wait
what was it Petrie the main character I
don't know that's the bat I don't want
to think about it that makes me cry let
me character um big full foot big little
big for a little fit Petrie shut up what
you brought it you anyway anyway anyway
um such a Peugeot right back that
cleared a little bit of a small war but
I I could not tell from what I played
and how help big and expansive it was ok
cool I saw some cool in the comments I
know if you can confirm this Callie you
can the robots drink oil from the ground
there's one like that they're like
they're called grazers and they were
always digging in the ground but I
wasn't actually pay attention to when we
were doing because I was trying to kill
them so sure they might be I don't know
if oil was that plentiful do you think
they would really have that big of a
problem with their society probably well
maybe like drinkable water becomes the
big thing yeah um so amazing 786 said
how meaningful and deep does the side
content feel are we talking Witcher 3
level a lot which are three comparison
because that kind of nailed the
open-world formula or average average
Ubisoft title
I would say it's certainly not at a
Witcher 3 level from what I can tell
obviously this game's not out so I don't
like say definitively but there were
like I went on side quests and it like
one of them was to help a lady find her
missing brother who had been cast out
because he attacked somebody or
something it was like this whole
backstory and she talked for like a
million years and um so it seems like it
it's a lot of world building inside
quest from from what I saw I mean there
were other kind of not fetch quest ii
things but it was like oh find some meat
for this lady and I'm like I'm not doing
that so I'm gonna get she can find
around meat so that's right cuz there I
didn't even like realize that there are
like rabbits and animals running around
as well yeah you can hunt organic matter
and you can kill people you got any
metal not it no nobody eats metal ass
like the Grinch Jacob white on Twitter
he's asking if there's an upgrade system
for like your mounts times were robots
did you get a sense that he's is pretty
much standard like um I was I treated my
mouth my mounts is disposable I would
like Rose override it I would right
amount to where I wouldn't wanted to go
and then I used it as bait and another
machine would attack it so I did not get
that far okay I was like yeah you can
just fight this machine for me I'm gonna
go gather things a lot of people are
asking there's gonna be a demo from the
for this game Michael court Oreo had
asked I don't think so i think that this
games out and it just went gold it's in
3-4 weeks yeah it was almost out so so
sadly we have to wait one thing that
sucks this game is out three days before
the TWiT there 544 four days before the
switch Nintendo switch four days before
a bomber like it obviously I don't think
they knew that before a nintendo
announced the release date of more on
march third this game is off every
twenty eighth yeah i mean i don't even
have me try to beat this game in three
days before you get in ten dose which if
you plan on it yeah i am really torn
because I've been wanting to play zelda
for so long but I really did enjoy
playing horizon and I want to play more
so it's gonna be a weird balancing act
between two open world games that are
very different cuz I don't think horizon
didn't seem like it's directly competing
with
if you're like super nintendo games but
if you're like saving up money for a
switch then it might be tough to do both
of those in one week especially a time
like between Zelda's open world like you
just said and horizon horizon it's not a
short game doesn't look like it no does
not look short yeah all rights
unfortunate but at least we'll have both
least would neither amarilla
embarrassment of riches yeah um and then
i think that was all the questions I
wanted to bring up right cool so yeah
that was our last segment on horizon
zero dawn that released febri for a
PlayStation 4 Callie has a preview up on
gamespot now you can go read that we
also have a few discussions from e3 last
year kind of outdated but still might be
relevant the cinematic trailers up on
gamespot you can watch that get a sense
of the story the game let us know you
think in the comments
[Music]